and here I thought you could talk to me
[Music]
I understand
so I took a shower and washed all of My
Essentials which I wasn't sure about but
kind of enjoy I then turned my attention
to more important aspects of my personal
hygiene
like taking care of my body with this
manscaped lawnmower 4.0
seven thousand
RPM Motor
leaves every shave fresh and me feeling
clean
and it's light make sure that I can
reach those unmashionable areas that I
just mentioned
should have used the manscaped Croc
preserver or reviver for all your most
sensitive areas go to manscapes.com and
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
promo code Crowder 20.
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Ahoy everybody and welcome to louder
with Crowder with Dave
what up son I'd like to welcome
everybody
thank you for tuning in uh also joining
me in the studio Gerald a how are you
I'm good how are you sir I'm pretty good
Gibby how are you talking now one as we
would call you on the show Ahoy to you
my friend how about you Casey Jones oh
good morning hey Tim the Tool Man good
morning Dave and one of my good friends
and special guest quarter black Aaron
how are you what's up it's good to be
back it's good to have you back all
right you weren't here last time I was
here and now you are I'm back I'm good
well I've seen you man I love seeing you
my friend I'm glad I'm glad you're
dinner every day you're looking good bro
family good oh yeah oh yeah you got the
drummer you got oh really in a way yeah
seriously you guys need a room bottom oh
yeah yeah we do could you please
sir
my son plays guitar you both hey we have
a band yeah what's what's your son play
nothing yet oh yeah yeah I guess yeah oh
I guess maybe we need a garage for our
awesome kids
so here's what
oh well if it's Notre Dame we'll still
be cooler ouch um
you lose
all right today we'll be talking about
uh sexual icon uh Jeffrey Dahmer and his
new Netflix show uh Alec Baldwin's uh
rust resume uh oh sorry resume his
resume is shooting a [ __ ]
a person a person I didn't mean I sorry
that came out wrong I I listened to a
lot of hip-hop yes yeah he's influencing
him yeah he's a [ __ ] yes
resumes uh Biden is a minority what huh
hmm U.S Intel reveals Ukraine carried
out assassination of a Russian
politician's daughter politician's
daughter is that true it could be true
well we'll find out we'll see Nick Rick
had his first interview after being
banned from YouTube and potentially
disbarred is that right well we'll see
we'll see they're trying he may be uh
late and uh
gay as the kids say on the internet I
didn't say that that's the internet said
that oh so we know okay well we're gonna
find out and of course it is Thursday so
we are gonna have super chat so thank
you guys for tuning in and question of
the day did you watch the Jeffrey Dahmer
documentary and if so what'd you think
I'd like to add a little portion to the
end did it make you hungry as well yes
did it did it turn you on it's a
different kind of Bros movie I'll be
honest I watched it on mute and made the
remote sticky all right
what you made it your own Dave yeah you
made it your own yeah well you cook
you're supposed to wash your hands oh
that's what it is you're cooking not at
home yes yes it's the worst the easiest
thing I could find it was terrible yes I
got hot as an oven oh Lord
does Netflix have a fetish with Jeffrey
Dahmer I feel like it's the eighth thing
about Jeffrey Dahmer that they've come
out with what is up with this yeah
there's like there's actually a movie
where he's a kid it's like my friend
Dahmer what's up with this what is the
fascination like I get it like one
documentary one movie maybe it's like we
don't need that story like Jeffrey
Dahmer joined the MCU like I want to see
I want to see everything it's him the
Night Stalker it's like
I want to see the movie I sold Jeffrey
Dahmer a giant tub of acid and no one
questioned me and I got away with it yes
yeah exactly that's my barrel of acid in
the corner what can I get you just need
a giant tub of acid huh coming right up
you look like an upstanding citizen what
do you need it for I work in a chocolate
factory makes sense
go
also Steven is not here today obviously
but you can see him this Saturday he
will be at Bricktown in Oklahoma City 6
and 8 45 for tickets you can go to
lottery.com my friend owns that club
it's a great great uh Club go check it
out and for years truly you can see me
October 14th and 15th in Liberty Heights
Ohio that's near Cincinnati at the Funny
Bone that is Liberty Heights Ohio at the
Funny Bone October 14th and 15th and
just announced November 26th 2022
Carnegie Music Hall in Munhall
Pennsylvania Thanksgiving Thanksgiving
yeah it's this the it's right after
Thanksgiving I think it's either Black
Friday or uh Brown Saturday one of those
days it's just one of those things which
other one no yellow Sunday is my
favorite I do like yellow Sunday yeah
relaxing it's not too bad yeah it's a
pisser so
the end
do you ever shop on Black Friday hell no
no I used to when I was a kid I was like
oh this is this sounds fun and then I
went there all it is is waking up really
early standing in the cold and like
everybody buying the TV before you yeah
I waited at ABC Warehouse
in the cold for five hours for a
television in 2007. yeah yeah and I'm
lucky I'm short because I'm not fast but
when it opened no one cared about the
line everybody just ran into the parking
lot Mayhem yeah yeah so I went in and I
slid under everybody like jingle all the
way because I'm small and I managed to
get the last TV and then when I got the
deal on it I told everybody and they're
like yeah I paid like thirty dollars
like more than that yeah it's not even
that much of a discount you know do all
this work yeah I'm like yeah I had
insomnia and got the flu and it broke in
two weeks yeah yeah it wasn't even a
good TV yeah not worth it it really did
it was like a DLP or whatever those were
called where like all the light bulbs
start going out and it's just like okay
you have like a blotch on the screen you
just can't see anymore it's the worst
but the Black Friday I got it on
blackboard well they you gotta just take
a camera and go to Walmart it'll be
worth it oh that's true trust me if
you're lining up early at Walmart you
made some poor life decisions oh if
you're just if you're just there just
weeps going everywhere yeah people
racing motorized carts
using reaching sticks to grab a
television that's mine it's a man over
there to take out the competition what
are you talking about
yeah that's true your weight just
depends on how fast the cart can go
like why is that going so fast ah that
fat [ __ ] put nitrous on it some people
run over
pardon my language all right I know many
of you know godly people all right
the animal kingdom is home to many
amazing metamorphosis caterpillars to
butterflies tadpoles into frogs and
whatever this is Friday October 2nd
Wednesday December 9th it's January 25th
2021. two days before my breast
augmentation it's Wednesday uh it's the
day record for my surgery April 20th
2022. today is Monday August 22nd
my God speaking of Black Friday you're
no longer invited to Thanksgiving
Wherever You Are
yeah wherever you are what why every New
York you know what
I gotta say being born with this body if
you're a guy that looks like that you
don't waste it
but the rest of us can't be as you know
douchey as you look I mean yeah tall you
know but he's tall and muscular yeah he
looks like a action movie character
seems like there are some other issues
what is that play no well then again I
guess he probably was using other
stimulants maybe maybe in the beginning
and then he decided to become a woman
which is fine always nothing which we
want everybody to own the YouTube land
there's nothing wrong there's nothing
there's anything wrong with that yeah
it's just just
go ahead say oh yeah no way
yeah we will definitely have to save it
for Mud Club that's very beautiful and
brave it's very very interesting kept
the sleeve tattoos as well well yeah you
don't want to get rid of those why would
you get rid of those no no no it's a lot
of extra work there okay you're already
spending a lot of medical Barbie look
money on and then kept the is that how
you feel Barbie's look no I I feel like
the giant breasts and trying to look
like this fake woman is a real woman
what world do you live in no no no
Barbies are fake women is what I'm
saying oh right the dolls right there's
this weird obviously the man turning
into a woman is a real woman real
authenticity can get pregnant can get
pregnant yes yeah scientifically proven
it's science all right before we get
there
it's so awkward dude
yeah that is a caterpillar into a
beautiful butterfly
just like you know yes yes indeed yeah
sounds moving on
um
good luck good luck to her though I hope
she
enjoys the gym
who not that she goes to the one that
bangs her all right so
um
where did she go to the Y because I
don't think anybody's gonna be dining at
it all right
um the Jeffrey Dahmer let's talk about
that you guys have heard of him yeah
definitely yeah yeah thank you you know
the Jeffrey Dahmer perfect yes yes go
right into the Jeffrey Dahmer I call him
the Jeffrey Dahmer I bet a lot of the
other ones have changed their name
the Dahmer family filed immediately like
okay we're not connected but let's
change this yeah anybody with the name
Dahmer uh pretty much since 1992 is like
let's not name him Jeffrey yeah yes or
Jeffrey off the table Yeah
consider changing our last name yeah
should we do that maybe you know because
of the you know you can the homosexual
that ate his friends
um
yeah
he ate people
[Music]
it's so terrible
[Applause]
I you know I used to do a joke on stage
whenever I was in Wisconsin about that
where it's like yeah I don't that's the
difference you could tell like between
like we women and men are always more
serial killers you know yeah like they
just the differences with the women they
just don't I don't know
eat people
you know you don't take that extra step
yeah so they might kill a guy but they
typically don't eat the person do you
have condiments the guys kind of do that
maybe a cinnamon they take it to another
level he wasn't in a plane wreck either
he just no no
I don't even think one of them were a
pilot
I've never tasted human maybe that'd be
a great excuse to be like look guys I
thought I was in the Andes I I was
tripping my bad my mistake you're in
Wisconsin I was fighting for my life it
gets very snowy here okay yeah that's uh
the so the
Dahmer monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story
has taken Netflix by storm if you
haven't seen it here's a short clip
[Music]
what are we gonna do
I told you
we're gonna hang out
I'm gonna watch a movie
I'm gonna take some pictures
and I'll pay you
I don't think that's what they're gonna
do what episode of louder with Crowder
did he put on
yeah what do you think they're watching
that's weird
yeah and the movie goes it's it's like
it's the eye Exorcist three I watch it
every day oh that's the moment you go
I'm gonna leave
before she does have a knife on him you
shouldn't walk into the house to begin
with not sure what that setup was what
is it prostitution or uh yeah uh well no
it's fifty dollars to take some pictures
oh 50 bucks to take pictures take
pictures Ah that's nice shouldn't that
be like a little bit of a war morning a
guy wants to pay you 50 bucks to take
pictures yeah oh inflation you know it's
yeah I mean
today that's fifty thousand dollars
next year that's gonna be a lot more
yeah we keep taking some pictures guys
yeah yeah but it's amazing back then too
the cops go into like these rooms and
it's like you know you have this top
this is just a big barrel of acids it's
the bat yeah it's just a vat of acid and
then just blood all over a bed and he's
like yeah it's just gay stuff and
they're like yeah it is we're gonna go
like I'm not asking any more questions
this is fine we see your barrel of acid
totally fine yeah no more questions I
have one too right don't we all the guy
has to look at 20 Polaroids of murder
until he goes these are real
together Polaroids
[Music]
this isn't photoshopped we didn't have
MS paint
but all the blood was like the cops were
like that's normal that's just yeah all
the time clearly just from sex ah having
a good time all right
don't want to judge yeah
none of our [ __ ] hey ass don't ask
don't tell that's your thing hey there's
a power drill covered in blood yeah
they're gay
and they like to do Home Improvement
projects together come on blood obvious
come on they're making soap in the other
room call that lie yeah right it's like
he's making sex zombies where he can rub
acid on the brain and make their arms
move
what he did that he did that yeah yeah
really yeah it's real it's real yeah he
found out through Roadkill
that his his dad taught him acid on the
brain of a dead animal it's orange is
still twitch oh my God so that's how he
figured he could make sex put your hands
in the air no he didn't yeah Bill Knight
did an episode on it it was like 95.
um
wow Bill Nye the sexual Science Guy
yeah Bill Nye after Dark
without them
there's a crossover with tales of the
crypt yeah exactly love it
just fun experiments you can do at home
look what you could do what you're gonna
need is a dead oh possum just take a
couple drips start twitching around look
at that grab some paper towels biology
take your pants off oh all right so
there is controversy though because the
Netflix uh show I don't know if you guys
know this it was initially tagged
lgbtq oh that's a bad look why would you
do that I love that because I hate that
that exists in the first place so I love
that they put this in it yeah well I
think it was tagged lgbtq uh personally
because Jeffrey Dahmer uh was the G he
was the G and lgbtq yeah these are facts
yeah yes he I mean it is an lgbtq plus C
for cannibal so I understand the offense
but uh this did this it prompted a not
so positive reaction from the gay
community
where the Netflix tag the Jeffrey Dahmer
documentary lgbtq
like I know it's technically true but
this is not this is not the
representation we're looking for you
don't get to pick your representatives
I'm sorry no it's I mean go ahead
comments let us know what you think do
you think that it's inappropriate that
they labeled it lgbtq or do you think
that it makes sense because there is a
lot of that in the show
yeah there's a lot of G lots of G yeah
nobody cares about the G anymore no
really the G's are really just s's now
straight so yes oh basically I thought
you were saying sassy
yeah both double meaning it's endearing
yeah they're both I mean it yeah I
wouldn't say that it was a it was gay
friendly
but it was there was gayness in it
definitely a little bit you take the
good with the bad sometimes that's The
Facts of Life really bad with Bros sorry
that's going to be labeled I'll do mean
to you I would be way as a gay person I
would be way happier with Dahmer being
labeled lgbtq than Bros
yeah straight people don't have a corner
on psychotic people right so we've got
people who may go out and commit Mass
murderers yeah just demographics eating
people killing people yeah like well
like let's say uh Henry portrait of a
serial killer he was straight I'm fine
with that yeah Annie Matthew McConaughey
romantic comedy don't like it nope at
least people are watching Dahmer right
that's true she's the interest people
list
[Laughter]
yeah oh they're in a parade that's cool
does anybody get murdered and eaten
during the parade no no thank you I'll
pass yeah no good uh so naturally
Netflix cave though and uh and and took
it down
come on have some principles right and
they shouldn't cave they've been pretty
good at night caving yeah that's what
I've liked about them because eventually
they're gonna be a dead service and they
might as well just stick with stick to
their guns what you got you know the
question is uh that no one is asking
though is is what would Jeff think of
this and he actually gave a statement on
the Netflix series and sent it
exclusively to louder with Crowder
hi I'm Jeffrey Dahmer and a lot of you
haven't heard from me since 1994 where a
group of prisoners sodomized me with a
broomstick and murdered me well I'm here
to tell you that was bad but I gotta be
honest it's pretty nice up here in
heaven
just kidding I'm in hell
I understand that there is a new show
out about me and the LGBT community is
offended
hey guys at least you have a community I
didn't have that I was always ashamed of
my sexuality in fact I was so ashamed to
tell my parents I was gay that I had to
take a mannequin from a department store
and make it my boyfriend
so just be happy nowadays if you have a
trans or a gay kid it's like having a
rescue dog
now there's black people I guess who are
offended by the show because they were
treated on fairly unset
and I don't stand for that most of the
people I ate were black and that's
because they had more flavor in soul and
I lived in a neighborhood that that was
mainly the community I don't stand for
racism
so this is Jeffrey Dahmer saying black
lives matter
we just like to thank Jeff for sending
that in yeah absolutely man what is his
hell having to have sex with women I I
don't think he's actually allowed to
even have those thoughts
I understand there's an all-you-can-eat
human buffet and he's not allowed near
it every hell scene we've seen we've
seen is like right outside each other
and stuff like that and movies and he's
like yeah this is fine wow that's not
such a bad place a little hot yeah his
house yes his hell is heterosexual porn
in a clean apartment yeah it's just like
and having to eat Wendy's where are my
VHS yes
uh well I don't like this at all it
doesn't smell like meat went bad where's
the human yeah
he gets vegan Burgers yeah
yeah it's a pretty girl delivering
doordash vegan
he's like come on what I did wasn't that
bad ah he also has to face everyone he
killed just ate a few people come on
yeah I said come on guys you want to
watch a movie again hey they're like man
you ate me and I'm only here cause a
homosexual stuff
that's not right man
way different things and you didn't even
pay me yeah come on you still owe me 50
bucks
[Laughter]
all at his door
I want those pictures man
well uh hit the like button please it
helps with our algorithm as you guys
know that and uh you know what we need
to talk about this about Netflix though
they do mislabel a lot of shows and you
know Dahmer isn't the only show on
Netflix obviously uh that's caused
controversy about their labels so let's
go ahead and get to seven plus one
Netflix shows that we're improperly a
labeled
foreign
in the chamber
there's always One in the Chamber every
time always forget it every every time
always forget it number seven hidden
figures fantasy
oh
it's a delay late on that that's all
right yeah I like I like the pause
number six QB who shot Malcolm X
because you watched
Medea Family Funeral that's why it ends
up in your suggested feed I get it now I
get those the algorithms it works makes
sense uh number number five
Hannah Gatsby Nanette comedy
[Laughter]
number four Gerald stranger things for
fans of the assistant Secretary of
Health
nothing to see here number three QB
surviving R Kelly Watersports
[Laughter]
number two pieces of a woman for fans of
Alec Baldwin
Netflix too soon I know right Netflix
come on man
I'm gonna give this to Gerald on purpose
number one thank you Virgin River
because you watched There Will Be Blood
Last Action Hero
for Gerald
and those offense
he likes that movie so uh I
those events seven plus one mislabel
Netflix shows
[Music]
you forgot the fan in the chamber
don't forget it's a live show Monday
through Thursday 10 a.m and you can join
us on Rumble anywhere where you can find
podcasts and of course please subscribe
to Mud Club it helps pay for this show
yeah that's what gets us our paychecks
oh look at that sign look at that do you
know how much that cost it's a lot it's
I made that sign
oh you did make that six into that and
we never changed it ever it's the same
size because it's so good
well we can't afford to change these
things we wanted to make an nft out of
it we were just a little late yeah I if
I use toilet paper I get screamed at
really they don't want me to use stuff
around here that's true dude wipes
expensive yeah toilet paper not
flushable yeah I know it says on there
that it says uh wipes are not flushable
change my mind
and like well the package says I don't
have time to debate it but we'll see if
I change his mind I just pile them up in
the corner
it wasn't a good meme to kind of make
the point that they're not flushable
right now
I will change yeah it's like I guess
okay I guess I'll flush him blush that's
the only debate I can give you is if I
try to flush them yeah ask the plumber
yeah I do like that we have a hole
though in the wall and Brian stelter's
looking through it that's really funny
little secret we have around the office
that I just shared Easter eggs
well uh the movie rust is shooting again
I I guess that's a poor choice of words
speaking of fans of Alec Baldwin uh yeah
uh it'll be I guess where they're gonna
really really check for blanks this time
really yeah do the best to not point at
the guns directly at gmail female who
knows for guns now so yes on set so
that's good it'll be the CGI them in
it'll be banana guns yeah it's gonna be
totally uh total Squirt Gun movie
because I would sign up to work on that
movie yeah it's gonna be R Kelly water
sport guns
yeah stuff
PP R Kelly I haven't heard about this
look at that big juicy booty what
but they're gonna start shooting again
in January oh so I guess they're gonna
let Alex celebrate Christmas before they
make him take no responsibility for
murdering someone
all right again but I'll tell you what
I'm gonna take responsibility for what's
that my messy balls
it is us it's the end of smooth
get that product out look at that
product that's what they're paying for
man it's the end of smooth sex summer
and now it's turned into fresh balls
fall so to start this new season get the
manscape lawnmower 4.0 you can use
discount code Crowder 20 for 20 off plus
free shipping at manscaped.com so when
your girl wants to see or guy I'm not
judging uh wants to see your balls nice
and smooth use this it's even got a
light on it for those hard to reach
tainted areas and uh yeah it's a
lawnmower
but don't cut your grass with it just
your man grass
[Laughter]
the ad could really be ladies men if you
need to shave your balls
yes that's true times yeah everybody
needs to shave their balls
yeah for all the men and women out there
with balls and the guy from the
beginning of the show yes anybody and
everybody with balls the the guy who
probably has night vision goggles in his
basement
for when he hunts people he brought home
from the gym ah no couch in my van we're
not saying that guy we're saying other
guys like the potential other guys yeah
Other Guys by the way have I shown you
my barrel of acid give me back my dog
manscape
I shaved the dog's balls
non-chafing experiences as well
sorry I shaved my poodle's balls
give it back it's smooth manscape
for you or your dog's balls
go to the gym
so Biden I don't know if you guys know
this yeah he's a minority of all kinds
he is yes wow yeah you might think he's
just white looks why he looks white yeah
and I mean white on white with the hair
too and Del Dracula you know that's
pretty white
like Leslie Nielsen playing Dracula yeah
and dead and Loving It yeah super not
Blacula no no no no no
straight up Dracula but yesterday the
good people over at town hall put out a
hilarious compilation of Joe Biden
claiming Community status in a number of
minority groups uh I I got raised to the
black church he knows I'm not kidding I
got my education
for real in the black church for real
and that's not hyperbole it's a fact
lady in the back
she will more than many of you did
you all think I'm kidding he can tell
you
I was sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home politically I just
have one thing to say
all right
[Music]
come on
man
it's like come on guys yeah that's
what's up
let's shoot an alarm every time his uh
cleaning ladies being assaulted by
Hunter
just plays it yeah
oh he's coming after my and she starts
dancing every time yeah
it does work stop yeah
look at you moving
yeah now Town Hall plays us off for last
but we did some digging and it turns out
that Joe isn't joking so guys go ahead
and comment and comment comment also if
you think that this is absolutely
ridiculous where if you don't let us
know your thoughts let us know your
feelings if you think Joe is actually
you know he's got a little bit of flavor
to him right yeah he does I mean how
many people he pointed out and said he's
he knows I'm not joking yeah I mean
that's like at least three people
clearly he's not a joke so yeah I mean
in the town hall yeah he's not kidding
around no but we did like I said we did
some we did some digging and uh here's
uh here's some photo and video evidence
of Joe's diverse background uh first of
all here's him with this Hispanic
community
oh
[Music]
look at that straight up look he's got
more way to dig for that one yeah yeah
man yeah yeah that's true
you don't he used to have a mustache you
did a little just a little pinstrap yeah
right there yeah it was white you had to
shave it it's very weird also suspenders
a lot with the wife beater yeah was his
style he'd do the the button-up shirts
but just the top button just the top
yeah just the top and sometimes just the
sunglasses and the mm-hmm yep nice he's
pretty bad back then yeah he was and
then he became a teacher if you remember
he did clean up comb over cleaned up
that school I must reach these Gates
mm-hmm
also uh here is Joe living uh live in
Black Culture
[Music]
it's your birthday
I see I detect nothing wrong there no I
mean he's much more ripped than we
thought yeah just no as somebody who is
black I mean you yeah yeah it's I relate
it's authentic right and it's 100
authentic
pushing those weights down yeah he's a
pimp not sure where the birthday thing
comes in with being in the weight room
and all that stuff but hey whatever well
it's Shorty's birthday it's his girl you
wouldn't know Gerald I wouldn't that's
what I said I don't know
shorty is his girl
Shorty's a girl right but he's and it's
her birthday that's her birthday on her
birthday then he's not with her on her
she's getting sexy for her birthday I
don't think that's how that works you
can't get foxy on her birthday for her
birthday Joe Biden is getting pumped for
that 12 year old girl yeah exactly
if you like it's my birthday I love how
I'm trying to pick apart a hip-hop video
yes like 20 years ago yeah especially
with 50 Cent yeah yeah it's gonna make
total sense he's actually just in rehab
trying because he got shot 38 times
Daryl's like I've had questions for 20
years
sense to me are you just trying to get
your arm muscles to work again why is he
upside down three slugs yeah ah here's
and here is of course Joe hosting a
podcast
yeah that makes sense yeah he's got a
beard now he might yeah
he's throwing it out very Jewish
uh he was great at the plugs though yeah
oh wow yeah snake cement oh wow
well now we're going to talk a little
bit about this uh I'd like to invite
Lane the brain in this uh conversation
oh I love Lane all right Lane's a good
dude well I don't know if you've heard
about this
um uh it is the U.S Intel says Ukraine
carried out a hit is that right yes yeah
come on sit in the chair I think he's a
little surprised by this but I know he
is and he's coming in we've had some
back and forth back and forth right over
the years I told him he must wear his
Shockers hat
well and he did and a shirt two size is
too small but he's got just right or
just right yeah you guys I think it's
Cheryl two things doesn't know hip-hop
and fashion yes yes yes
you know some hip-hop before the show
I'll give you fashion nothing I actually
I I pulled I was like I know this like
there's I'm getting around like it's in
a hip-hop song I was like that's Tupac
that's right that is true nailed it you
and Kamala me and Kamali I well I smoked
with Kamala where's your hot sauce man
and I I always carry hot sauce
yeah when she used to smoke blunts yeah
I was in his 1970s smoking blunts
listening to Tribe Called Quest hmm
um that happened yes and she's a liar we
know that yeah so she's she likes her
sex all right
the so let's talk about this I don't
know a lot about it I'm not going to
pretend that I do I think everybody
knows that so that's why I've brought in
two people who actually understand
politics all right I pretend
yeah well so if you want I can I can set
it up and then give us yeah why don't
you take the wheel Jesus all right uh so
U.S intelligence has concluded that the
Ukraine was responsible right and they
they did this I think it was the New
York Times uh I'm sorry Wall Street
Journal article
um where they said that they were
responsible for the August assassination
of Daria dagina dugina
um and if you're not super familiar with
who that is Lane I know you know who
that is that was a really big deal
because that was somebody who was uh
assassinated on her way home from a
festival that her father had been
speaking at with a Car Bomb yes right
and I believe they said that she was
driving her father's car and there maybe
was an attempt on the father's life now
the father is a super pro Russia Pro
Putin Pro attack in war in Ukraine guy
right you're gonna have to lean into the
microphone just a little bit you're like
you're like yes this is my cool guy yeah
this year now we're good yeah is he
flexing like this you know just I don't
know what to I don't know what I don't
know what to do with my hands all right
no we're good there but yeah so her
father is I guess like an imperial
Advocate he's like when they invade
Russian Empire yes
not Star Wars I mean I don't know what
his opinion is on you know Return of the
Jedi or anything but he is definitely
his whole thing after Russia invaded
Ukraine or invaded Crimea in 2014 was
okay this is the first step in
recreating the greater Russian Empire
yeah you know Catherine the Great style
way before USSR so they he has a brand
Ambitions very far right I guess he's in
cahoots with Steve Bannon they're not
like friends but they they've run in the
kind of the same Circle a little bit
about that a little bit they don't I
don't yes all right so this guy
Alexander uh Duggan Dugan I can't even
Dugan Dugan no a because he's a man yeah
that's true Alex Zan alexandar
he's
is basically known as Putin's brain
right so he's kind of who who would be
the equivalent in the United States it
certainly isn't Kamala Harris
as Biden's brain he doesn't have one of
course we'd have to go down the list a
little ways to be able to find one but
it basically right-hand man to some
degree Putin is who this person is so
this is a ballsy attempt no matter who
goes after this person killing the
daughter oh I wouldn't do that on air
Dave
I'm sorry Gerald you were talking in the
gun pointed at my mouth yeah it did it
by itself right this is a really ballsy
thing but so shortly after the incident
Russia said that Ukrainian special
forces were responsible for awaited
right so of course Russia would say
something like that and so nobody really
believes and they're like yeah of course
you would say that it's the ukrainians
that did it and maybe they did maybe it
was the United States but most likely it
was somebody in Russia who didn't like
the war right is that is that basically
sum up where we were until this article
came out yeah so I guess that was the
thought when it first happened is
Russia's like oh Ukraine did it well you
know of course they're going to say that
it's hard to trust their state media
apparatus just like people don't want to
trust the U.S media the mainstream media
but have given a lot of credence to what
the Russian media said says which is
weird right there was a lot of distrust
there obviously
um so the thought in I guess U.S circles
the more mainstream circles was anti-war
person yeah that doesn't like this we
hoped that was the thought yeah right
but that would show descent against the
regime within Russia right so here's the
problem with all of this and the reason
that we're covering this story is it's
sexy that we're talking about an
assassination that happened a while back
no but here's the issue if it is true
that the Ukrainian government knew not
saying zelinski knew there's no evidence
that he knew or sanctioned the hit but
if they knew this is kind of part of the
problem that we've had with Ukraine from
the beginning right so Ukraine comes out
as the underdog somebody needs to defend
them the world comes to their aid we
give them money and part of giving them
money was saying do not escalate with
Russia right we're giving you money to
defend yourselves you guys are being
attacked now you're defending and then
they go oh well we've got the backing of
the rest of the world we've got all the
arms we've got all the support we've got
everybody on our side now we can do
something stupid like this because we've
got our friend over here who will take
care of it if it escalates because of
this that's what pisses me off about
this story because if they did that they
are basically betting with our money
yeah it's essentially like having a big
brother that's going to protect you and
you know he's going to protect you
from bullies which is great but now
because you have that confidence you go
out and start picking fights with other
people well that's not what the brother
signed up for that's not his
responsibility to stop you from being
stupid this would be a stupid decision
on the ukrainian's part it sounds really
patriotic and great and everything but
when it comes down to the real politic
of the situation doing this isn't going
to gain them any friends right and it
would be detrimental to their overall
war effort right if it's true yeah and
the U.S intelligence seems pretty sure
that the ukrainians did it yeah and
basically this is kind of like you know
your girlfriend picking a fight with a
really ripped athlete and you're like oh
geez like the guy from the first video
yeah yeah well in the beginning even
role I guess he could play both roles in
that yes
essentially yeah right so on the
transition yeah you know just to be
clear the United States had not shared
information with Ukraine that would help
them Target Russia Russian officials and
we had that from the Wall Street Journal
as well and assassinating a political
figure in Russia is certainly an
escalation and we said look if we're
going to give you these 40 billion
dollars in military aid since The
Invasion you guys have to play by our
rules and it doesn't seem that they have
right so I know that the Ukraine Russia
story just seems like it's this
never-ending Story the big issues right
now though are okay we're supporting
somebody who's obviously corrupt and a
leader who plays penis piano which we
talked about and saw the video yesterday
right which is why I'm for him well that
sounds like a positive I thought that
was kind of cool that's a skill
kind of cool I think that's so freaking
hacked imagine stupid but he can do
other places yeah no but it was real you
play the piano with penis no but I can't
even play with my fingers I can act like
I'm playing the piano with my penis
though I mean can't we all I tried it
last night uh um but I think and I was
in the hospital it's already Ukraine is
already having trouble with the US
public a lot of them not wanting to help
at all of course and I know I follow
Garrett's Twitter sometimes often every
time we sign a new bill Garrett says
stop giving my money to Ukraine he does
every time every time but that that's
the sentiment from a lot of people right
we don't want you to escalate this war
because now what we're talking about is
Russia's Annex these portions they
officially signed those documents I
believe today or yesterday making those
part of Russia so any attack in that
area is an attack on Russian soil so now
it kind of changes the calculus because
Russia has said that they will view any
attack on their soil as an attack on the
Homeland obviously and they will respond
with whatever overwhelming force that
they can muster maybe nukes Maybe full
mobilization whatever it may be right so
it's just escalation that's what we're
seeing right now and we don't need
Ukraine trying to pick a fight any more
than they already have like just defend
your country that's fine don't go
assassinating people in Russian
leadership right and I think this goes
back to I the people in this sphere of
media I guess like more right-wing media
a lot of them tend to be very
anti-zelinsky anti-ukraine which oh hold
on let me just cut to CNN not not the
guy in the parade who's wearing a mask
who killed those people but the
watermelon rainbow lady yeah are those
bananas yeah that's banana jacket and
she has a rainbow earrings to cover a
murder trial she definitely bought that
at a boutique yes Middle
America's been operated by a Facebook
yes that's just fun to point that out
real quick we do have to cut to CNN
anytime there's someone ridiculous on
which is almost every minute I'm sorry
to cut you off please go no no we're
we're wrapping up yeah the only thing I
wanted to end on is there's this I guess
predisposition for the right to disagree
with things that left her supporting the
life supports Ukraine and they come out
and like okay I hate zielinski I hate
the ukrainians they're Nazis whatever I
don't think a lot of that's true but
when zolinski starts trying to push the
envelope when ukrainians are
assassinating Russians in Russia you're
going to lose more and more
international support and that's not
good for anybody that's not good for
Europe and it just seems like zielinski
and ukrainians are have a good hand but
they're trying to push it further than
they should right absolutely so and now
this woman though
got hit with a uh Fair Point what it was
she what she was she got a car bomb that
she was like like she was Ace Rothstein
what's up not uh not being able to get
out before it blew up yeah so that's but
I mean she was that's how she was
assassinated was via A Car Bomb leaving
a festival yep okay so we'll see what
this goes I hope uh I hope that if I
mean
I am not for any escalation in this same
because it's just going to lead to a
really bad place because Putin is backed
into a corner and a very dangerous
person backed into a corner with nuclear
weapons I don't know that he's going to
use them don't get me wrong I'm just
saying you don't even want to have the
fear of somebody using these because it
changes everything for the world if he
does right it puts us in a position
where we either allow strong men in
these countries to use nukes and go oh
finger wag finger wag right I can't
believe you did that I can't believe
sanctioned sanction we're gonna take
care of it or there's no fingers after
the nukes go yeah that's the same thing
those are your options I don't see well
there's more of them oh yeah do you
think India and Pakistan are gonna their
nuclear power do you think China is
going to do anything do you think
Japan's gonna do anything to Russia for
this do you think do you think anybody
in the European Union is going to do
anything because they're right next door
you want to be next
it's the United States having to step up
and do this that's my thing that's why I
think it's either finger wagging which
is basically what we've been doing this
whole time just sending support to
Ukraine fine but not actually taking
actions that would stop this from
happening because he's got more you can
just shoot more of them if he wants so I
just don't see a very good outcome for
this and I don't see a good president
being said yeah I've seen a lot of
passion behind this for the Ukraine
online like a lot of towards the shows
right I'm wondering why you know what is
that about and feel free to comment why
why you feel this way you know we do
want to know your opinions and don't
think that I've seen a lot of people
like honestly angry to the point of like
I'm canceling because of this don't
don't do that because of a difference in
opinion why do you feel maybe
differently about it feel free to write
your your opinion and your congressman
and your Congressman especially you were
going I was like wow I haven't heard
that in a while right please write your
Congressman I'm sure they're going to
read it yeah they'll do something
yeah feel free to call your congressman
and touch yourself on the phone
I hear you've called in and I'm
interested yes what are you selling how
are you doing if it's me no I just think
what I don't think there's a lot of a
lot of weapons yourself going on there
with Congressman why are you Whispering
you realize that I don't want to talk
about I mean I didn't I didn't know how
where the line was when we're talking
about sitting congressmen and
masturbation we didn't Point anybody out
as far as the line goes either insane
like that I have concerned people might
take me more seriously yeah I don't know
there's a I don't know about a line
I think the congressman I I guess the
line is the stall at the airport or that
they're tapping your foot under my foot
no not your foot the theoretical the
theoretical three foot I'm not saying
that you go to airports and are like
sure hope there's a congressman
no I I do I go to Minneapolis nice well
I think we're still are we waiting still
waiting on our guest we'll uh we'll see
do you have an update on that for us at
some point we'll see how long that's
going to take to get him on here but
trying to get but they're saying that
with this whoever was trying to kill her
was likely trying to kill her dad is
that accurate we have an overlay here
yeah in the New Yorker
that wasn't you
that was the situation don't say us like
I had anything wrong with Lane
um
I appreciate that why does he get a pass
yeah I don't look at him okay Lane's
awesome
it's that Shockers yeah I don't see you
in a Shocker's house go Dane cookers
see well there
he just gets a shovel keeps digging
yes I do my friend it's the only thing
you can do okay so we went through all
this all this business right all that we
went through all the 40 billion yeah did
we cover that did we send them 40
billion so far that's what I thought I
thought it was more than that yeah I
think we've committed to more than that
but we've actually sent it
okay I'll ask you this they say there's
this monies already paid for and bought
whatever that means what the hell and
I'm wondering what that means too like
it's in a warehouse does that mean we
can't just take the money it's like a
joker pile of money and these are just
burning they're just like all right
going to the Ukraine I don't know it's
already paid for bank account is doing
A-Okay yeah like why can't that help I
don't know Florida yeah that should
probably be able to build a wall right
you'd assume right maybe feed some
hungry people yeah like all the homeless
people that are in every single city in
America now I get it so Garrett your
opinion on this is what overall Ukraine
don't like it okay well
let's color man in the business for
nothing
you said color to her I did not stop it
at the end that's a major league quote
all right not a fan I don't like it um
you know it's it's like meddling in
other people's business I know that
there's like a more there's a larger
game at a foot you know with like Russia
and whatnot but it's like the more it
seems that America like meddles in other
people's Affairs the more they mess it
up right well it's been proven over
decades and decades and decades yeah it
does not help well it works in Vietnam
yeah yeah yeah totally worked out there
well we do have a guest so let's talk
about that all right thanks to uh QB got
him on the show today and I want to
welcome uh nickata
[Music]
Nick how you doing thank you very much
for joining us today
hey buddy thanks for having me pretty
much appreciate it oh my pleasure uh I'm
Dave and of course you got QB in studio
here what's up man oh wait he's on here
yeah I'm sorry uh gee guys I I gotta go
uh I Gotta Go My dilation schedule is is
late I gotta leave right now I'm sorry
wow wow and we got a lane here and uh
Gerald a as well we'll be asking you
some questions
um but yeah the cry bullies have come
for Nick if the audience doesn't know
and he has been banned from YouTube
after I guess his third strike uh we
have uh we but we do have them a lot
with yeah we have a lot to ask him today
is what I'm trying to get at and uh so
we relied on a lot of your stream during
the Cal Rittenhouse and uh Johnny Depp
Amber Heard trial coverage but for those
in our audience who don't already know
your work uh can you tell us about your
law practice before and before the
YouTube and sense
uh sure yeah my um so my law practice uh
was was pretty it routinely gets uh
maligned and slandered online but uh it
was uh my own office it was just me solo
practitioner in a small town in
Minnesota
uh I I was very very proud to hang my
own shingle and and kind of get to work
I mostly represented uh criminal clients
and then of course uh you know that's
in a small town criminal law is hard to
like just pay the bills by yourself
unless unless you know all of the meth
dealers right then it's really easy yeah
but um
but if you only know like one or two and
they dry up or you know you get arrested
too much uh it you have to do something
else so what I would do is uh it's just
no income that way right I would do
business entity formation uh I would
draft contracts review contracts you
know go through commercial lease
agreements and all of those fun things
along with a little estate planning so
um okay anything you know any any kind
of really though it was it was uh it was
called paycheck law uh because there's
anything that paid you at all right
is that Johnny Depp behind you
uh yeah that's a Johnny Depp painting
but uh yeah a friend of mine named Eric
Waugh he's a fantastic artist uh and
Michael Myers same dude yeah we've got
we've got uh no this was uh this is a
guy who has passed away his name is
Robert Hurst oh I'm sorry I feel well
that's awkward it's okay he's great uh
he mostly painted sports figures but he
had this one horror painting you can't
see it all but it's it's Michael Myers
it's uh Jason Freddy Krueger Pinhead uh
and Leatherface oh dude that's awesome
yeah sorry I completely went off I just
I thought that was so cool behind you so
I apologize uh no that's very cool how
dare you I know right I I yeah you enjoy
my stuff you son of a [ __ ]
so what uh so how did this band come
about
oh well it uh it all started
uh back in July with my first with my
first of the three YouTube strikes
um which was completely bogus uh so if
people have already been there yeah as
they usually are Gerald knows about that
yes YouTube has a they have a policy
against graphic content and that policy
states very specifically that you can't
post certain content intended to shock
or discuss your your audience
and so I got tagged with that because I
don't know if you guys remember there
was a knife fight in an Australian mall
where um this club circulated a lot
these guys were kind of going back and
forth swipes and the one guy he like
stands there for a minute kind of bleeds
on the ground then he just dies out of
nowhere and so I have a five hour live
stream
and about four hours and 20 minutes into
it I played this 40 second long video
clip and then I go on to comments about
how senseless this violence is and how
young men's pride get them into
situations that get them killed and it's
a complete devaluation of life and it's
a waste of potential and uh that was
deemed in violation of the rules which I
find to be incorrect because I've showed
I've covered police shootings I've
covered you know stabbings and stuff
like that on the channel uh plenty of
times I've never had a problem
um but that was my first strike
wow yeah we had that where we it was a
girl who stabbed or a cop who shot a
girl preventing stabbing another girl
correct yep exactly yeah yep yeah yeah
and see and I covered that one and
didn't get a strike yeah so yes
arbitrary well yeah and what we were
saying was we're like hey I'm glad that
the cop acted to save the life of
another individual we weren't
celebrating that somebody died we were
just saying like I'm glad the police
officer was otherwise that person was
getting stabbed she was in the process
of stabbing yeah right right and I think
that's what that was a strike
it was uh it's crazy because you you
cover something like that it's very
clear like well we don't want this
person shot but Yay good job cop because
you saved someone's life and I I tend to
do like legal analysis or I'll bring on
another guest and we'll talk about use
of force and stuff like that and uh so I
covered that case I probably showed that
video 10 times uh no no issues never and
and I never had any issues with strikes
um around graphic violence doing that
before but it was like okay and so I've
been I've been working to this day on
trying to get that strike removed uh but
I had until October 22nd the next strike
is where things get a little interesting
for me
and that's um I I was critical of this
weirdo uh on the internet called uh
keffels uh have you ever met a weirdo on
the internet I mean they're rare I mean
I I've only heard stories around the
campfire but I guess they exist
so uh there's this there's this weird
person named keffels and a strange
website called kiwi Farms which this is
such like deep internet but keep kiwi
Farms is where kiwi Farms is where a
bunch of people with problems go and
whine about like online celebrities to
to sum it up in a in a pithy way but
people go talk about e-celebrities and
and have gossip but they also collect a
lot of information about them
and and this particular person had a
history of boasting about how they would
get uh hormone replacement therapy this
is their words okay two kids as young as
12 years old without their parents
consent they would either help them find
it from various like third world
factories that would Supply it without a
prescription or uh sponsoring a website
that allegedly had a step-by-step
do-it-yourself estrogen kit oh so a
crime hmm yeah I mean yeah yeah you
could be one yeah right you know if you
were guessing
right so I I I very politely and very
calmly on a live stream once suggested
that that was uh that was something that
was abhorrent to society and uh and I
used a euphemism
to suggest that maybe maybe people who
harm children uh and and do this without
their parents consent don't belong in
polite Society
um that was that was spun into I called
for the murder or execution of this
person that was the lie that got
perpetuated on Twitter something I do
not and have not done uh at all
that is uh right and and so this person
uh part of their their thing like I
guess their content creation is to get
their Twitter mob to go after people who
go against their agenda and so I got
build is like this anti-trans uh thing
which is interesting because in the same
video clip just 10 seconds later I said
I don't care about trans people like at
all if you're 18 you want to do whatever
to your body go ahead like it's not my
business just stay the hell away from
kids please like that's that's all I
think that's a reasonable request but
yeah I also don't think you should be
able to order by mail any kind of
surgical or hormone treatment kit yeah
it's like a different aside there that's
an interesting I don't think you should
have a chemistry set when you're like
seven yeah you should have to wait till
21 to drink booze but hormone
replacement therapy whenever go ahead
here's a syringe and yes you guess
Andrew can pick them up at the
Scholastic Book Fair now yeah right next
to the eye spy novels yeah
I don't trust you
I don't trust you to make pizza rolls if
I'm not home but yeah go for it here's
my Lamborghini poster and my sex
replacement there it is right yeah
that's right there
look as as someone who may be returning
to small town criminal law no I
encourage chemistry kits for every
seven-year-old but it should be
mandatory at this point and also give
them a hefty supply of Ritalin and uh
whatever other drugs are necessary to
make into better ones yes seriously yeah
I encourage Sudafed and chemistry sets
yeah I'm actually just working right now
with uh with the pharmaceutical
companies to have my business card in
with every 10 pack of Sudafed
but so this this act of mine uh very
much angered them
um I received a strike in a two-week
suspension uh for that they then
proceeded to to go after my uh my law
license yeah because because I said
something that they didn't like and
um they they try they organize uh ethics
complaints I received 45 ethics
complaints on the same day so that was
fun so this is just kind of like a but
this is just sort of a mass group of
people all doing it together it's not
really a real
I mean people's a stretch Dave
yeah that's a good point uh so I should
say it's is this one guy
no it's not it was a whole bunch of
people okay in fact uh the funny thing
is when you submit an Ethics complaint
um but the guy is very bigoted I don't
know when you submit it yeah sorry
that's true very gendered which they're
using their days so these CIS people and
yes possibly not
[Laughter]
we'll go to bug club here in a minute
and be able to speak yeah yeah let's go
yeah we will go to Mud Club here in a
minute I think that's a very good idea
um yeah let's do that what do you guys
think go to my club yeah stay with us
where you could find yeah Nick right now
on Rumble so if you are trying to look
for him ricada law on Rumble that's
where he is right now so and that's what
we're about to be yeah because we're
gonna go over to mug club actually
because I'm a I don't know what
questions I can even ask on this
platform I know right now because it
doesn't suck like we're just having an
honest conversation about what's going
on and we can't even we can't even say
what we want but before we go to mug
Club really quickly just a reminder
Steven's at Bricktown Comedy Club
Oklahoma City Saturday October 8th six
o'clock and 8 45 tickets go to
ladderwithcrowder.com tour for that
you're in Liberty Heights Liberty
Heights Ohio next weekend I will be at
the Funny Bone October 14th and 15th
Kansas City Missouri the week after that
and come out davelandow.com check me out
there all right join us on mug Club but
until then subscribe to the show and uh
we're not you're not really sorry
can I interrupt you yes just a second I
I had prepared a list of racial slurs to
read on the show oh before we went to
mug Club is that okay oh of course
that's afterwards
oh dear God well it's actually a game
where we see if ours match
Bingo all right until then piss off
YouTube
[Music]